You guys want to see my coachella look get ready,
Hi, my name is [Grace]. [Helbig]. If you did not know now you know. Your life is different now
Coachella has ended. I think but no one knows because it seemingly goes on forever
But the second week of coachella has come to a close
So I thought like I do with a lot [of] different events I would review some of the more popular
fashions that we saw at Coachella 2017
I took some of your suggestions from Twitter and then I found some other photos online let's review Celebrity coachella [fashion]
2017. Selena Gomez and The Weeknd wow okay. There are a couple now. Which is cool. They're cute
they both look like
You know parents that are ready to take their kids to a theme park and stand in line [for] hours on end
[they] packed the appropriate footwear. Other than that Selena gomez looks like a roll of fabric from Jo-ann Fabric that
Is always on sale because it's gorgeous. Selena looks very Delia's Circa
2010 GURL
G-U-R-L dot com anyone out there? Fun place for girls to connect and also an even more fun place for like predators to..
nevermind.. and The Weeknd
Looks like how quilt that a woman who frequents Jo-ann fabrics made for her emo
nephew. This it also looks a little bit like The Weeknd log rolled down a hill or sh** his
Pants, and then log rolled down the hill [and] I'm okay with that. You got to do what you got to do
at music Festivals bathrooms are at a minimum?
Cute guys ! Katy Perry. Katy Perry debuted a very short haircut at Coachella
And why not. Here's the caveat to Coachella
No one dresses incorrectly nor does anyone dress correctly. Everyone's thrown like a thousand bouncy balls in a very small
cube all at the same time that's like what I imagine coachella is. Side note, I've never been to coachella
So nothing that qualifies me more for judging the fashion at Coachella
It's the fact that I've never [been] to Coachella. Katy Perry is giving me sexy Fred Durst Vibes
And I don't hate it but Katy Perry also has a great sense of humor about this because she posted on
4/20 a photo of her her new haircut
side by side with Guy Fieri's. So I feel like she makes fun of herself as much as everyone else [like].. Rihanna
[this] is why I f**king love
Coachella and I also love Rihanna
[this] is exactly..yes give me more of this. This is so stupid. This is so stupid
It's so smart and it's so dumb and it's so..
I love every part of this Rihanna apparently walked around the festival grounds wearing
this masked bedazzled
full length bodysuit and no one knew that it was Rihanna, and I love that kind of [sh**]
And I love that she also just put like a normal festival outfit on top of it. The other thing
I heard is [that] this suit cost seventy five thousand dollars
So that's where this fun prank falls out of my favor, but other than that like yeah, this is kind of shit
I want more of the Coachella outfits to be and you're so cool Rihanna, but like I know you know. This is just f**king stupid.
Lorde! I love Lorde. I like her music
I like her energy her vibes. I might be a little biased because she liked a tweet that [I] tweeted about her and
Her song 'green light'. She did not follow me, but she liked the tweet
And that's the first step to a real friendship. This stage outfit looks fun
Feels like sexy, Las Vegas showgirl on top and like sexy insurance [Saleswoman] on the bottom. Tax Season's over
Fancy accountant get on that stage at Coachella. She always looks fun and comfortable
Fun-fortable rolls off the tongue. This is Orlando bloom and Leonardo Dicaprio
I don't think that anyone has told them that by putting their hoods up. It doesn't make them invisible.
[they] were still able to tell who they are. Maybe their ears are just cold in the desert.
Maybe they both got carried away with the music festival and they got
matching bro piercings on their ears
They're just a little embarrassed by the decisions that they [made] so [they're] just trying to keep them under wraps. I get it boys.
Paris Hilton! I read somewhere that this is Paris Hilton's 10th Coachella.
And you would never be able to tell. This cheshire [cat] is in heat!
Her body is glowing very sweaty in a very glowy
sexy way. This is like a really sexy boho party City birthday banner that you turned into a
Maxi dress and I think that's really cute and the cat ears are
putting out that vibe, that people should think cats are sexy.
I don't get that so much, but like cool chest plate, and you're really doing some fun heart eyes emoJi cosplay here. Cute!
Kylie Jenner this doesn't look like your typical coachella
And maybe that's why I kind of like [it] the dress is very like
Sexy South Jersey Girl Chainmail. The hair is very
like I want to supercuts and got my hair bleached blonde,
And then my friend said "come swim in my pool"
And her dad like over chlorinated the pool and so it turned kind of green and then I borrowed these boots from my brother
who's in this punk-ska band and
There we go.
[I] relate to this on many many levels
surprisingly. Hailee Steinfeld! Steen-field. Stern-field. Steen... Stinef.. Sexy meets sweet we got some [S&M] type boots. We got
Fishnet
Bodysuit and then we got shorts that look like mom let her daughter get her first pair of like "short-shorts"
But they're frilly and cute. This looks like you [shopped] at the Icing and [then] also the serious
Girl section the weekend before easter, Cute!  Vanessa Hudgens! This is..
Yeah, you kept your throne as the reigning queen of Coachella. Vanessa Hudgens, if you don't know is at this point, is
Just really known for being at Coachella. [I] feel like and this year she wanted to make [sure] that
everyone knew their place
She got a Lisa Frank folder printed on about 50 yards of fabric and she wrapped around her body and she just
Flew off! Mitch Grassi and Scott Hoying
[superfruit] was at coachella and they look like
superfruits! Look at these boys. You [guys] are so cute also
[I'm] going to use this as my Christmas card for 2017 is that okay?
I hope that's okay. Troye Sivan look at this kid is this not the [cutest]
Burglar you've ever seen. I'm sorry I am such an affinity for Troye. I just feel so proud of him, so
Adult and be so cool. I like to get a lot of unfinished ends on all of your clothing.
So for anyone out there is OCD. This is a really complicated outfit to look at but still very
Stylish [I] like it. We can see both of your knees
So we understand that you are with legs and not just standing on Wooden stilts
That's cute, and I just like the whole like a adorable burglar vibe.
The girls from ClevverTV!  [oh] my God I don't know if you guys follow any other [girl] from Clevver. I love them so much. Look at these girls
They're having the best time ever and if they're not they're really really good at pretending
They're having the best time ever for a great Instagram. this looks like an ad for a college that I would like to attend
May I enroll please?
Thank you. Okay!
That's it for my review of the Celebrity Coachella fashions from
2017. Let me know who you guys loved and if I miss anyone which happens constantly.
I'm very sorry I cannot please all of you, but I hopefully please some of you?
If you like these fashion review videos give this video a thumbs up so I know and subscribe to this Youtube channel I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes. Other than that I don't know.
This took a lot of time
for what is seemingly a
Minor payoff. Ain't that just Coachella [though].